[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight for many years decades in fact
Harvey Weinstein's conduct was an open
secret in the movie business the public
may have been oblivious to what he was
really like but the people who knew him
and worked around him knew that Harvey
Weinstein was a creep and a predator it
was glaringly obvious some of them were
brave enough to joke about it and award
shows congratulations you five ladies no
longer have to pretend to be attracted
to Harvey Weinstein
so when Ronan Farrow began an
investigation into Weinstein's behavior
didn't take long to unearth a mother
lode of evidence evidence that in fact
the fame movie's producer was a monster
it was a remarkable scoop that kind of
reporter's dream about so Farrell and
his producer took their story to
executives at NBC where they worked but
instead of congratulating them the
network killed their investigation
Farrow who later wrote a book about the
experience explained it this way look we
had a story that journalists looked at
and said this should get on air
immediately we had a recorded admission
of guilt from Harvey Weinstein secured
during a police sting operation this was
a case where a news organization didn't
behave journalistically they ordered us
to stop to not take so much as a call
and to cancel interviews in some cases
with alleged rape victims this book
explains why pharaoh's book is a
best-seller tonight on the Amazon list
NBC meanwhile has not budged its
executives still claim they did nothing
wrong they didn't kill the Weinstein
story they say NBC News chairman Andy
lack call Pharaoh's book quote
fundamentally untrue news division
president no Oppenheim called it a
conspiracy theory who to believe in this
well maybe the most powerful
corroborating witness in this story has
received relatively little attention so
far his name is rich McHugh he was a
reporter in the investigative unit at
NBC News and he was Ronin Pharaohs
producer McHugh spent eight months of
his life working with fair reporting out
the Weinstein investigation ten days ago
he published a story in Vanity Fair
about it
makuu's piece amount
one of the most devastating accounts of
malfeasance by a television network ever
published get yourself a copy of this
story it is jaw-dropping and elac had no
Oppenheim McHugh writes quote not only
personally intervened to shut down our
investigation of Weinstein they even
refused to allow me to follow up on our
work after Weinstein's history of sexual
assault became front-page news as the
record shows they behaved more like
members of Weinstein's PR team than the
journalists they claimed to be and quote
now that sounds like overstatement but
as you read the story you realize it's
not an overstatement at all they did act
as PR agents for Harvey Wednesday the
story is crammed with damning detail the
cumulative effect is so overwhelming
it's so clearly true that NBC hasn't
even really responded to the story they
said they've ignored it hoping it'll go
away in fact just today The Wall Street
Journal reported that NBC has and this
is remarkable even by their standards
renew renewed Owen Noah Oppenheimer's
contract it's expected that he will take
control of the entire company soon